Now, Bob, Carol, and Alice who are going to come in later are finally having their meeting.
Well, I should say something about Carol's algorithm,
but Carol already has a bit more experience with algorithms than Bob or Alice.
She has already figured out that a simple algorithm that you just try
all the possibilities of selecting certain investment opportunities
into her portfolio is just not going to cut it.
Carol is really looking forward to meeting Bob and figuring out some new ideas.
At the beginning of the meeting, Alice is not there yet.
Bob and Carol started explaining their problems to each other.
Bob is explaining to Carol how among a set of genes some of which are connected.
He is looking for groups where every gene is connected to every other gene
and Carol, of course, explains her problem
where she is looking for potential investments that are not connected to each other.
such as this one here.
Now, in order to not have to talk about genes and investments anymore,
we should use some common terminology for both of those problems
and if you already have an algorithm's course,
you might have come across a structure known as graphs.
and graphs are basically just objects that are connected to each other.
The network up here at would be called a graph
and the network down here would also be called a graph.
This here, the object would be called a vertex
and of course, this, this, and all of these objects are vertices
so this would also be a vertex, here, either the purple or the green ones
and then the connections are called edges.
All of the blue connections or some of those that I've colored green here
every single one of them is an edge.
An edge always connects to vertices and the whole structure is called a graph.
And if you used that terminology, you can state the problems
that Bob and Carol are working on using a similar language.
Bob's problem is basically taking as input a graph with n vertices
and the output that he is looking for is the largest set of vertices all connected to each other.
What Carol is looking for, again the input is a graph with n vertices
and the output is the largest set of vertices not all connected to each other
that non-connected to each other.
As you can see, once we use the common terminology, the problem that Bob is working on
is actually very, very similar to the one that Carol is working on.
The only difference is Bob is looking for a set of vertices where all are connected to each other
and Carol is working on a problem where none of the vertices are connected to each other
but everything else is the same.
You are given a graph with n vertices, you are looking for the largest possible set,
and all it's about is the connection that these vertices have to each other.
In the future, to be better able to talk about these problems,
we'll also give them names as we do with most problems
Also, so that we don't always have to say this is Bob's problem and this is Carol's problem.
What we will call Bob's problem is a problem named Clique
because all of those vertices are very closely connected to each other
just like in a clique of friends for example
And we'll call Carol's problem independent set.
Carol is basically looking for the opposite of a closely collected clique.
Carol is looking for vertices that are not connected to each other.
If those were friends, they wouldn't know of each other.
Now, after Bob and Carol have explained their problems to each other
and given them the name, they noticed since the only difference
between clique and independent set is that in one we're looking for all vertices
to be connected and on the other one we are looking for none of the vertices to be connected
That problems are actually very, very closely related,
and I will show you the idea that they come up with to figure out how similar these problems are.
also from an algorithmic perspective.